alright so welcome to this talk on using
my sequel sorry no sequel from home
language so the purpose of this talk is
to show you what is an entry point with
an ink with our existing technologies in
Mathematica where you can connect to no
sequel and I know no sequel usually
deals with very large data sets and here
i am showing you two of those common
ones one is the [ __ ] DB and neo4j and
the topics that you will be seeing here
will go through what no sequel means and
some of the basics about how MongoDB
handles the documents and then we'll see
what's the connection configuration what
are the settings that you need to do
from MongoDB and from mathematical side
and how to create a retry update and
delete documents and some of the basics
of neo4j and configuring and doing
operations on neo4j so no sequel is a no
new standard for storing data which does
not rely on the sequel standard and the
document could be of any form it could
be like a key value pair the data can be
stored in a key value pair it could be a
graph based data base column or just a
plain document there and some of the
examples like Cassandra that's by Apache
and mongodb and neo4j so let's go
through the first one here MongoDB this
is a document based database and every
document consists of elements which are
of the form field and value and this is
stored in the documents in the form of
this is the binary JSON format and the
way databases are represented here is
you have outer collection which is
nothing but a collection of different
documents and each document has a set of
elements which are filled and then value
now if you want to connect to these from
Mathematica so this is basically how you
would describe a MongoDB collection so a
collection is a set of documents and
each document contains certain elements
with a field and then a value associated
with it so if you want to connect to it
from matt Marika with the existing
technologies there's two ways here
either you can use one of the drivers
that come with no sequel many people
have made these drivers available free
for download and here i will be using a
dotnet based driver and link it to the
dotnet link technology in Mathematica so
to get started first thing you need to
do of course is to install MongoDB and
here's the download link for that so
when you launch it you move to the
directory where MongoDB is installed you
start a [ __ ] DB server and and a client
there and if you are working from within
math America this is the location if you
are working with a java-based driver
that's the location where you want to
store your driver or jar files and if
you are working with.net link that's the
location where you would put the driver
files so I'm going to evaluate that and
the part would differ if you're on a
different platform so the first thing
that I did again was does download the
driver and place it at those locations
in my Mathematica installation directory
the next thing to connect to MongoDB
just load the dotnet link package that
comes with math America and then start
the dotnet runtime once you get a link
object that means that the runtime is
now started and then I just made a
wrapper function around the dotnet the
kinect function within
now the MongoDB driver to connect to the
database so I get back a dotnet object
when I evaluate the connect to MongoDB
function and that means now I'm
connected to it so to show you the set
of operations that you can do here we
will first try to create a collection
which we will call a user data and then
we will try to create a few documents
and then insert some elements into those
documents and document into the
collection so I have a MongoDB running
on the side here so as we do changes
from Mathematica will check if those
changes are taking effect in the Moga DB
actually amount okay so here's some set
of functions that i created this is a
function that will create a collection
so let's create a collection named user
data now I need a document where I can
store my elements so I have another
function that will create document for
me and then I will call that function to
create a set of documents there I want
to create my elements here and this will
be a field value pair so I have three
fields name age and status and then I
insert a few more sets of data in the
same document here so i have my elements
ready and all i want to do is put those
elements into my document and lastly
when I have my documents ready I want to
insert my document into the collection
so we can see these are all just working
on top of the functions that come with
the driver so I just use mathematical
functions on top of it here so let's see
if my documents are available in the
user
data so you can see that if I show all
the collections within my database now
user data exists there and if i want to
check if all my documents have been
inserted or not so all my documents are
now into the database okay so you are
done the insertion operation now let's
get back the data into mathematica so
here's another function I want to see
how many collections my database
contains so here's another wrapper
function so there's only one collection
right now which is user data that we
just created and here's another gate
function so this gate function actually
gets an enumerator so I have to look
through every element apply some kind of
a loop structure there to go through
each one of the documents and collect
the key value pairs and that's how it
works there so I get all my data here
now the good thing about using this data
with Mathematica is that Mathematica has
this built-in Association function which
basically relates a key and value so
here I have my keys which are name age
and status and I can make an association
on top of it and then convert it into a
data set and then once I have the data
all I need to do is query the data set
itself to get any specific data that I
want so here I'm getting all the people
whose age is about 30 and all the names
if I want to so no more I don't have to
communicate with a database all through
here because i have my data set already
in the mathematica colonel okay so here
here's another function if you want to
update some rows of your document here's
another function that we've created and
this function basically takes the
connection
name of the database you want to update
the collection name a matching feel and
a matching value so wherever you feel
you've ever it finds a field that
matches this value update it update the
fields with the updated value so here in
this one wherever the status is a update
the age to 30 and if i evaluate that
let's check if it has updated we didn't
have yeah we have one field here one
document here where the age is 30 and
that should change sorry we were
updating wherever the status is a so
wherever it found the status as a it has
updated the h 2 30 there so so the bases
here is that if you have a driver for
any dot net or java even python python
is not actually a supported one but we
do have a python link that comes with
Matt America you can make this wrapper
functions put the driver at a certain
location that matematika can recognize
and make this wrapper functions on top
of it and get the data and communicate
to and fro with your database okay so
the next debates that will be looking
here is neo4j this is a graph based
database so data is represented in terms
of nodes here and the relationships are
represented here like as shown in this
graph so it each node has some
properties here so here I have name and
a person here named John and Country USA
and they're related by this nose
property so John knows david and john
knows johan and johan knows david and
neo4j works on this language called as
the Sifl language and if you want to
connect the first thing that you need to
do of course is to have your neo4j
running so you can download it
the download link and i have i'm using
the near forger community web server and
version 2.1 point2 now here i will be
using a java-based driver when I
downloaded this driver it had a version
check within it which would not allow me
to work in a very straight wave here
with the mathematica and so basically
what we did was downloaded the driver
source and we changed the code a little
bit and recompiled it and the driver
will be available if you want to have
this notebook and this is the one that
works perfectly with Mathematica so once
you have neo4j install you can start it
and you get a screen something like that
and I have it running here and since
we'll be using a java-based driver here
so i will have to first load the j-link
package which comes with matt america
and that makes available all the Java
functions within Matt America and then
start the Java Runtime now the driver
you have to make the JRE or the java
runtime aware of where the driver is so
there is a function in jail inc which is
add to class path so you point the
classpath to wherever your driver is
using this ad to class path function and
then the same way how we did using.net
and mongodb we just make this function
on top of the the kinect function that
is in the driver here and do that in
mathematica and just call that function
ok so what this gives backs is a java
object once you have the Java object
available it means that the connection
is established now it's a little easier
to work with Java drivers because of the
flexibility and even the documentation
is much more clear when you're using the
Java driver here and so I made two
functions here one is execute query so
this will take any queries like create
something and execute it so it doesn't
really return back anything much and the
other function is get data so this will
take queries that will actually turn
some data so let's go ahead and create a
graph here i am using directly here on
the connection object that we got when
we connected using the Kinect function
and then I'd create I can directly put
the safer language query in the execute
query here so this is going to create
the same graph that you saw before in
this first slide here if I evaluate that
okay now we can go back into our neo4j
and see if it has created something so
we have our all the three nodes created
here and now i will run the get data
function which will let me get some data
based on whatever criteria i give so i
want to return the node which has the
name david there so it gets the all the
information about David and some more
functions here I want to just get the
names of these people so I get all the
name here so I'm just doing order by so
it will order it alphabetically I want
to get the country's list of countries
here now a nice thing that you can do
here is to use a mathematical
functionality of crafts so you know
there's you can make use the graph
function in Mathematica and make your
own nodes and connect them together so
once I have the data from neo4j I can
make a graph that looks similar in neo4j
same in Mathematica so that's what i am
doing here so from the data that i have
from the graft that we created in neo4j
so this is what Mathematica gives and
this is the same as what you see in
neo4j okay and then if you want to
delete something that you can just put
your safer query in execute queries
going to delete and if you want to
delete all the nodes here all the nodes
are now gone if you want to check there
so i just deleted everything that we
created here